millions of americans are hitting the
road and heading to the airport this
holiday weekend despite the high cost of
gas and airline tickets aaa reporting
that more than 39 million americans will
travel 50 or more miles over the
memorial day weekend that is up 8.3
percent from last year and it brings
travel volumes almost in line with those
we saw all the way back in 2017. and it
all comes as the average cost of a
gallon of regular gas remains at a
record high four dollars and sixty cents
i've seen even higher around here and
the us government reported that in april
alone one month the cost of airfare
surged more than 18 percent the largest
monthly increase on record brian kelly
also known as the points guy is here
with his tips on how you can save some
money on your summer vacation mr points
guy thank you very much thanks for
having me
answer the big question how can we save
some money it doesn't seem like there's
any savings out there there are deals
out there and this is what i'd like to
push people instead of having your mind
set on a destination
choose your destination where the deals
are so on google flights they actually
have an explore map so you can put your
home airport and then it'll show you on
a map where the cheapest flights are so
plan your vacation that way instead of
trying to just go to one place where
everyone else is trying to go instead of
having your mind made up exactly go
explore go somewhere you haven't been
before have some adventure so should you
should you wait to book travel if you
have coming up
we've seen airfare increase you know
march to april was the biggest one-month
increase it's been up over 50 since
january and demand just keeps going up
and up so on google flights there's also
a tab that'll say if the flight price is
average or below average i would say if
the fare is decent and you're
comfortable with it book it now because
we see all the indicators are more
people traveling and the biggest thing
to increase demand will be when the u.s
government drops that kova test to come
back internationally yeah americans
still have to get tested one day prior
by the way if if you're going abroad
never get tested abroad you can bring 25
why never get tested because you can
bring your own proctored binax now test
for 25 you pack it in your suitcase and
then you do it from your hotel room you
swab yourself they watch you on a video
and you get the results in 15 minutes so
don't waste money going to really
expensive clinics and risk it exactly so
is that the thing you think because it
says if there's one thing you're going
to pack if you go internationally is
that way next now and also as an added
tip get global entry global entry
it also gets you tsa pre-check because
the tsa short staffed immigration is
short staff so avoid all those lines
it'll be the best hundred dollars i like
global entry and i like clear but queer
isn't is is is not everywhere just yeah
right i think clear
you also say you shouldn't stay in a
hotel that's surprising not necessarily
shouldn't stay in a hotel you should
just understand a lot of you know hotel
prices are through the roof and services
are down you know you may not even get
housekeeping room service so take a look
and understand you know what you're
getting because you know that's why so
many people especially families now are
booking home rentals because if you're
not going to get the daily housekeeping
anyway why not get more space and
potentially in a better location i was
at a hotel recently and they didn't have
room service and it was very upsetting
you know that's one of the main things i
like in a hotel but you know what's even
better is ubereats once you get used to
it you're like why would i ever order
room service that's overpriced and bland
when you can get local restaurants that
come in half the time at half the price
cause it comes in a paper bag as opposed
to
a tray
dale
[Laughter]
all right if you're traveling with kids
uh any tips on making that a little bit
less stressful so book in advance and
assign seats at booking even if you have
to pay a little bit extra because what's
happening is airlines change the flight
times and they may change your plane and
your your seats may be scattered all
over the plane so well before your trip
today check your itineraries make sure
your family's still together and i do
have to shout out to delta they're
actually instituting family seating
they're blocking out sections of the
plane just for groups of families that's
nice i think is a hopefully other
airlines because it's stressful to
especially if you've got small kids also
be scattered around the plane and not
everybody is nice about changing exactly
i would never deny a family if they
wanted to sit together
unless it was a middle seat
[Laughter]
and even then i i wouldn't beat it kid
i want this
window would let a family i would let a
family sit together
but yeah
exactly but back to nate's question
about you know where you should go to
get the best deals yeah you said you
should google first and see what are the
best deals
i mean i'm still big internationally
canada there's cheap flights to toronto
and they've really relaxed their coveted
restrictions europe is on sale so
basically how to be replaced for sale
because the us dollar was almost at
parity it's a dollar seven to the euro i
remember 15 years ago it was a dollar
45. so the u.s dollar is really strong
and uh so europe's on sale paris we're
seeing airfare less than 500 so it's
cheaper to go to paris than it is to
miami and the dollar strong once you get
there
uh and then also like instead of costa
rica and mexico go off the beaten path
nicaragua is an amazing beach turf
destination also i love colombia the
dollar goes really really far brian
kelly valuable information we appreciate
it's really good also learned that gail
wants that housekeeper